[Musique]
on saura tout ce point de vue nous
sommes vendredi nous allons tout donner
pour ce dernier numéro de la semaine
avec deux invités exceptionnels bonsoir
renée fregosi soient ravis de vous
retrouver dans cette émission philosophe
politologue
vous avez longtemps été l'une des
patronnes du parti socialiste
jamais vous avez exercé des
responsabilités importantes
non mais vous savez que mon prochain
livre qui sort en avril s'appelle
comment je n'ai pas fait car et au ps
alors là on est c'est vrai je vais vous
avez vous avez en charge des relations
internationales c'est sans hésiter gré
du département envoyer mes parties
sociales
moi ça m'avait impressionné vous avez
aussi été jusqu'à l'année dernière
directrice de recherche à l'université
paris iii et votre dernier livre pour
l'instant jusqu'au prochain tente de
nous faire le teasing comme on dit en
bon français français encore un effort
pour rester laïque a été publié aux
éditions l'harmattan
bonsoir gilles smadja bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de cabinet du maire de
nanterre et vous avez été journaliste à
l'humanité
nous on va parler si vous le voulez bien
du coc vite figurez vous peut-être
avez-vous noté que hier la mairie de
paris a proposé un recond paiement
préventif en quelque sorte de trois
semaines dans la capitale l'idée étant
d'essayer de de vous couper les pattes
au virus
grâce à des mesures très strictes pour
pouvoir repartir ensuite d'un meilleur
pied
c'est une proposition qui n'a pas
forcément enchanté les parisiens si on
en croit les radio trottoir qu'on a pu
suivre sur les médias depuis hier et du
côté du gouvernement c'est pas non plus
enthousiasme ecoutez jean baptiste
djebbari le ministre chargé des
transports
anne hidalgo d'ailleurs maire de paris
propose trois semaines on ferme tout à
paris tout confinement de tri strict et
à prix on trouvera tout elle a peut-être
une bonne idée capacité visionnaire en
matière scientifique et épidémiologique
que je n'ai pas donc hidalgo délivrer ce
qui est étonnant c'est la certitude ces
trois semaines ferme et avec la
certitude de voyage je pense que
l'expérience assez concrète de la
propagation du virus de ces vagues
successives des variants aujourd'hui
devrait à tout le moins nous permettre à
chacun d'exercer un peu d'humilité
et le premier ministre s'est à son tour
exprimé pour dire que c'était des
fadaises
d'ailleurs du côté de la mairie de paris
le ton a un petit peu changé en ce matin
le premier adjoint emmanuel grégoire a
enfourché son vélo pour rétropédaler
expliquer que non finalement c'était pas
une proposition mais c'était plutôt une
hypothèse et puis que bien sûr ça ne
devait pas être limité à paris écoutez
que la politique des demi-mesures qui
consiste à compléter par séquences en
rajoutant des difficultés aux
difficultés sans résultats sanitaires
probant pose la question ou pas de
l'arbitrage de la part de l'exécutif
national sur un confinement plus dur
évidemment cette hypothèse ne peut pas
concerner que paris n'en est pas
question
je redis que ce n'est pas une demande de
notre part il n'a jamais été une demande
de notre part mais simplement une
hypothèse que nous souhaitons mettre sur
la table
c'était pas une demande c'est une
proposition on apprécie la nuance sur le
fond j'ai eu ce match avoue trouvé que
c'était une bonne idée ou pas cette
proposition
déjà il faut il faut quand même voir
qu'on est en train d'évoluer dans la
manière dont on appréhende les réponses
à la l'épidémie persistante voire encore
en augmentation c'est à dire que on voit
bien qu'il ya une vraie volonté de
donner des réponses territoriale
localisé en fonction de l'observation
que l'on a de ce qui se passe et on voit
bien que la situation n'est pas du tout
la même
selon les différentes régions par
exemple à paris en aide alors elle se
justifie déjà un une
une mesure vraiment paris intra muros
n'a aucun sens un dispositif qui ne
s'appliquerait qu'à paris intra muros
n'a aucun sens aujourd'hui on est dans
une vie métropolitaine on part le matin
de chez soi de nanterre on va travailler
à créteil on passe par paris on va voir
de la famille dans l'essonne
et voilà ça c'est comme ça aujourd'hui
vous avez des millions de gens qui ce
qu'ils font un territoire métropolitain
et il ya un brassage de populations
d'habitants de salariés tout ça fait
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui résonnait
simplement paris intra muros il faut
raisonner paris proche banlieue
métropole du grand paris 130 communes 6
à 7 millions de dhs habitants c'est à
cette échelle là aujourd'hui qu'il faut
raisonner alors est ce que un
confinement du strict va automatiquement
se traduire par une baisse de l'épidémie
franchement d'abord ça n'est pas du tout
à mon rôle de vous de dire ça on va pas
se lancer dans des prévisions jusqu'à
présent tous les gens qui ont fait de la
prévision dans ce domaine ils se sont à
peu près systématiquement plantés il ya
une chose que l'on peut dire c'est que
dans tous les cas de figure il y à au
moins un domaine qu'il faut absolument
préserver et là je vous parle comme
quelqu'un qui connaît ce qui se passe
notamment dans l'est dans les
territoires de banlieue c'est l'école il
faut absolument veiller à maintenir les
écoles ouvertes parce que on a fait
l'expérience il ya un an de la fermeture
des écoles pendant plusieurs semaines et
ça ça s'est traduit par un vrai
décrochage d'une partie des enfants
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
et ça il faut absolument l'éviter vous
courant vous où le maire de nanterre de
cet immigré qui déménage
vous avez pas parlé non pas du tout non
en fait il en est pas là on avait ce
matin la maire du 9e arrondissement de
paris dans ce studio pour le talk et
elle disait qu'elle non plus n'avait pas
été mise au courant
renée fregosi est tout aussi
enthousiaste que gilles smadja sur cette
fois position sur la même ligne en effet
je rajouterais juste que quand même là
un idéal go a réussi un tour de force et
qu'elle a mis d'accord contre elle
tous les épidémiologistes parce que en
fait cette solution effectivement comme
vous disiez parce que l'optique c-zéro
qu'ovide or 0 que vides paris intra
muros c'est mais d'une absurdité totale
surtout trois semaines en fait l'option
zéro que vides
elle n'est pas prise en france parce que
ça peut fonctionner en fait si on prend
des mesures dictatoriales qu'on enferme
les gens chez eux qu'on les contrôles
mais absolument du matin au soir
bon donc c'est pas l'option qui est
choisi par par le président notamment
par emmanuel mâcon donc c'était une
absurdité à mon avis aussi du point de
vue épidémiologique
mais ce que je trouve grave quand même
c'est que l ajout est là avec les nerfs
des parisiens et je crois que on n'est
déjà pas mal
à bout de nerfs et qu'on joue comme ça
avec nous en nous faisant peur en
permanence cette menace qui plane du
confinement
c'est c'est assez pénible à vivre je
crois peut lier d'airbus pardon je vous
passe la parole mais que c'est pas à
l'inalco elle même qui a fait cette
proposition
j'imagine qu'elle ait tous les courants
mais elle s'est montrée damman abrité
derrière son premier et hier sur une
radio et ce matin pour recadrer un peu
les choses comme on vient de le voir
avait pris la parole au nom de l'art au
nom de la municipalité on a l'impression
qu'on perd quand même un petit peu de
vue quels sont les objectifs à atteindre
pour essayer de retrouver une vie
normale
est ce que l'objectif à atteindre c'est
zéro co vide
moi je ne crois pas le pour moi je
tel que je le comprends le principal
objectif à atteindre
c'est de réduire la pression dans les
hôpitaux notamment dans les services de
réanimation
c'est faire en sorte qu'il y ait le
moins d'hospitalisations possible et que
les services de réanimation ne soit pas
au bord de l'eau bord de l'explosion
c'est ça l'objectif à atteindre est donc
c'est pas et rocco vide qui va permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif c'est pas du
tout 0 qu'ovide si demain il ya une
persistance de l'épidémie mais que ça se
traduit pour quelques pour un certain
nombre de gens par le fait qu'on est un
peu malade qu'on est à la maison et que
c'est pas grave ça c'est pas très grave
ce qui est grave c'est quand ça met en
danger le service hospitalier et la
réponse à ça je suis désolé pour le
moment il n'y en a qu'une c'est pas et
rocco vide la seule réponse qu'on ait
trouvé c'est le vaccin c'est le c'est le
seul moyen qu'on a avec certitude demain
de faire réduire la tension dans les
hôpitaux la question d'ailleurs se pose
à partir du moment où on accepte l'idée
que la situation n'est pas du tout la
même
en ile de france et en bretagne en
bretagne la tension hospitalière c'est à
dire le taux de co vide dans les
services de réanimation 27%
il ya d'ailleurs des municipalités des
communes plutôt de moins 5000 habitants
dans le morbihan où vous l'êtes plus
bill exactement le préfet a pris ce a
pris cet arrêté il ya qu' il y a
quelques jours donc à partir de là la
question se pose est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas aussi territorialisée la réponse
vaccinale
c'est à dire est ce qu'il ne faut pas
par exemple mettre le paquet sur le plan
vaccinal dans les territoires qui sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation
épidémiologique très très dur très tendu
et donc du coup mettre davantage de
vaccins là pour précisément réduire le
nombre de gens qui peuvent développer la
maladie et qui sont susceptibles d'être
hospitalisés ac signer davantage en
moselle à dunkerque ou et en
ile-de-france alors juste vous avez l'un
et l'autre employé l'expression zéro co
vidal le zéro comme une espèce de deux
thèses
qui va être expliqué pas plus tard que
tout de suite par karine lacombe c'est
une infectiologues bien connu alors
qu'il n'est pas contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens croient membre du
conseil scientifique qu'il s'est jamais
trompé et je sais pas ce qu'il s'est
jamais trompé en tout cas elle 0 coville
elle y croit et elle s'en explique sur
rtl c'était ce matin donc le zéro cowitz
est actuellement de imposé comme vous
dites une mise sous cloche qu'on espère
pas très longue de quelques semaines
mais assez drastiques et dès que l'on
sort de cette mise sous cloche mettre en
place les moyens que l'on a actuellement
une disposition que l'on n'avait pas
l'année dernière mais que l'on a
maintenant qu'ils sont la vaccination
donc vacciner vraiment en masse qui soit
également le fameux dépistage traçage
isolement que l'on ne peut pas faire
maintenant parce qu'on a beaucoup trop
de cas qui se transmettent vraiment
insister sur le télétravail peut être
réfléchir sur des périodes courtes sur
la fermeture des écoles
vous n'êtes plus partagé sur twitter que
sur ce plateau
selon vous pose la question êtes vous
favorable à un confinement strict dans
le but de faire disparaître l'économie
l'épidémie pardon de gobi 19 c'est non
mais à 57%
c'est relativement partagés il ya cette
question d'oreille ou tubes canton par
confinement au confinement strict bien
par exemple un confinement strict les
écoles sont fermées alors que ça n'est
pas le cas actuellement les des
transports en commun sont très limitées
aussi dans le cas d'un confinement
strict et puis le même aura est nous dit
y aura les héros qu'ovide avec 67
millions d'habitants en france
allons vous convient pas non plus comme
sérieux je ne ferai aucun commentaire
sur cette professeur de médecine en
revanche aura opté pour ça vous l'aimez
pas à nos jeunes je ne fais aucun
commentaire sur les différents
professeurs qui passent à la télévision
j'ai mes opinions et moi même je fais de
l'épidémiologie en amateur depuis dix
ans donc je vais vaguement jeu peut
vaguement suivre vaguement à je survole
bon je suis pas spécialiste
non mais le zéro co vide ici c'est un
fantasme c'est ce qu'on fait
la chine c'est ce qu'a fait la chine
c'était la stratégie de la chine mais on
a vu combien de temps ils ont confiné de
façon dictatoriale c'est une dictature
eux ils ont appliqué bon et on n'est pas
sûr que ça soit 0 que vite d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui en chine il y en a peut-être
encore qui traîne un bon mais en tous
les cas ici comme vous le disiez moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
c'est pas du tout l'objectif qu'on peut
poursuivre donc il faut effectivement
alléger les les services de réanimation
et l'hôpital en général et il faut
vacciner oui il faut vacciner en masse
avec quoi on est en pénurie de vaccins
donc effectivement votre solution
elle est transitoire a vraiment très
court terme
oui concentrer les vaccins plutôt dans
les zones où il ya le plus de
circulation du virus mais c'est vraiment
très
histoire parce qu'en fait ce qu'il faut
je sais bien mesurer exactement c'est
une gestion de la pénurie
non ce qu'il faut absolument c'est s'est
accéléré l'arrivée des vaccins
parce qu'on nous dit et c'est très bien
les généralistes commence à vacciner
avec astrazeneca c'est très bien mais ça
suffira pas on leur donne quelques
dizaines de doses en pha beau donc on
est dans la gestion de la pénurie et
c'est de ça qu'il faut sortir absolu ce
que ce que m'inspire la proposition de
du professeur lacombe sait qu'il faut
vraiment que ce soit les politiques qui
décident vraiment d'ailleurs elle dit
moi je propose sarkozy oui mais à force
de vous voyez ça me jette le trouble ça
ça crée de la confusion dans l'opinion
parce que quand on quand on prend des
décisions à l'échelle d'une ville d'une
région d'un pays
sur quelles mesures on prend on prend
tout en compte
on prend pas seulement l'aspect
strictement médical en compte
on prend l'aspect économique l'aspect
social l'aspect psychologique
on évalue économique oui c'est oui bien
sûr c'est ce que je viens de dire c'est
l'aspect on évalue les conséquences que
ça sur des millions de gens sur leur
travail sur leurs réductions l'éducation
des enfants
on prend tout ça en compte et je pense
que souvent dans l'intervention d'un
certain nombre de spécialistes qui
monopolisent beaucoup qui sont très
présents sur les plateaux des
télévisions des chaînes d'info en
continu je pense qu'ils ne prennent pas
assez en compte l'ensemble des éléments
des paramètres avant de avant d'avancer
vers des propositions
nous nous prenons en compte les
internautes c'est donc je relaie bien
volontiers leurs commentaires celui de
péage sur youtube qui nous vous assure
que le confinement ça ne marchera plus
yoann sur lefigaro.fr qui fait écho à
vos propos gilles en disant que karine
lacombe et médecins mais l'économie ne
se résume pas à la santé que ce soit
clair on ne maîtrise plus rien nous dit
je peux t'y 74 sur lefigaro.fr au moins
c'est clair comme éclaire la réflexion
de kriss kross non au confinement
j smadja est ce qu'il ya un hôpital à
nanterre
oui alors il ya une question peut-être
que vous pouvez y répondre l'esm
question de bobo 12 sur lefigaro.fr
des rumeurs font état d'un décompte
exagéré d'occupation des lits en
réanimation n'en fait on pas trop alors
il nous est un hôpital mais qui n'a pas
de service de réanimation mais là c'est
vrai que pour avoir discuté pour en
avoir parlé avec un certain nombre de
médecins hospitaliers
c'est vrai que il ya une question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est que quand vous
êtes hospitalisé par exemple pour un an
suite à un accident de la route et que
vous la première chose que l'on fait
quand on vous arrivez à l'hôpital c'est
que vous faites un test qu'aux vide si
ce test est positif on va vous
comptabilisez dans les hospitaliser
qu'ovide ah oui oui même si vous n'avez
pas même si c'est pas là pour le même si
ça n'est pas la moue le motif de votre
hospitalisation alors sur combien ça
joue on estime à peu près que ça devrait
de l'ordre de 2 5 à 10 % il ya eu des
papiers d'ailleurs là-dessus dans la
mauvaise spécialisés pour dire
qu'effectivement c'était sans doute il y
avait un système de comptabilisation
qu'il fallait peut-être voir et puis
d'autre commentaire celui de fil qui
explique que zéro co vite cela
reviendrait à suivre le modèle chinois
effectivement c'est ce que c'est ce que
vous disiez voilà y at il d'autres c'est
n'importe quoi ni charbon blot moi c'est
clair on ne peut pas mettre paris sous
une cloche une icône 06 qui considèrent
sur lefigaro.fr qu' il n'y a pas
vraiment différence en tout cas elle
n'envoie pas entre le confinement et le
couvre-feu
si quand même avant 18 heures vous
pouvez vous déplacer librement qui n'est
pas le cas
cher nicole 0,6 dans le cas d'un
confinement
et puis rémy sur youtube raismes pardon
sur youtube qui explique qu'ils
considèrent qu'il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le virus
les restrictions de liberté ça suffit
affirme t-il voilà je crois avoir fait
le tour de
vos interventions vous n'hésitez pas non
plus être aussi cette remarque que de
vole pas eu 34 si nous respectons
strictement les consignes sanitaires
nous n'en serions pas là t'as fait ça
ces accords avec ça c'est un vrai
problème parce qu'en fait on n'étudie
pas assez la différence de perception
des risques chez les différentes
personnes vous avez différentes
catégories socioculturelles qui
perçoivent le risque de façon différente
et donc génération du oui mais c'est
générationnel c'est sociologique c'est
culturel c'est plein de choses très
complexe en fait qui se croisent donc
c'est comme toujours ya jamais eu une
seule cause à un phénomène mais et donc
le port du masque qui est quand même
c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga mais c'est
vachement important il n'est pas
respecté par parfaitement partout et on
sera sûrement tous d'accord sur ce point
je vous propose de passer un sujet qu'il
a vraiment rien à voir vous connaissez
peut-être médine c'était pas mon camp je
vous la voûte ray et franchement mais
c'est un rappeur bien connu rapport à
vrai ça fait rire
gilles qui lui le connais c'est devenu
une évidence et
il y a actuellement un sorte de bras de
fer entre lui et la députée la
république en marche
aurore bergé député des yvelines alors
engagé il ya quelques jours je crois que
c'était si nos confrères de lci a
considéré que médine et est un rappeur
islamistes alors sur quoi est ce qu'elle
se basait pour ses déclarations bien sûr
des paroles tirées de son dernier album
jeu proposant d'en découvrir quelques
unes ce n'est pas forcément ce dernier
album d'ailleurs mais c'est un album qui
s'appelle jkd c'est déjà tout un
programme
je suis l'arbre de la laïcité avant
qu'on le met à terre dit-il notamment
dans ses chansons je me suffis dallas
pas besoin comme laïcise et puis aussi
crucifiant les laïcs art comme à
golgotha golgotha c'est le 7 collines à
la frontière de jérusalem sur laquelle
selon l'évangile de christ a été
crucifié
laurent berger a donc tenu ces propos
mais des lui a demandé de s'excuser ce
qu'elle a refusé de faire
c'était hier matin sur ses news non je
ne présenterai pas d' excuses ce matin
c'est un sujet sérieux puisqu'il avait
été invité à y faire une conférence
alors qu'il avait dans ses paroles de
chanson appelée à je cite crucifier les
laïcards crucifier les laïcards je
considère que c'est un appel au meurtre
je considère que ma liberté d'expression
et ma responsabilité en tant que député
c'est de dénoncer ces dérives qui sont
extrêmement graves
cette invitation fait une conférence est
et à l'école normale supérieure et
devant ce refus de roberge et de
présenter des excuses
médine a déposé une plainte
votre avis sur cette sur cette question
c'est renée fregosi grâce à votre livre
français encore un effort pour rester là
et que vous êtes très mobilisés sur ce
sujet oui c'est vrai moi je suis pas fan
de rap
même si j'adore les à l'action d'un mais
je laisse quand pas de la même façon
mais mais moi j'ai entendu parler de
médine donc pour la première fois en
justement à propos de ses chansons et du
fait ensuite qu'il a voulu faire qu'il a
fait ou qu'il a voulu faire un concert
au bataclan et c'est donc j'avais
entendu parler de cette chanson qui de
cet album qui s'appelle laïque avec un
cas et donc j'ai été regarder évidemment
sur internet aussi ces images des photos
donc pour moi comme ça de l'extérieur
il a choisi sciemment un look salafistes
c'est un loupé qu'il s'est choisie mais
je pense qu'il a lui plus tôt une
stratégie frériste des frères musulmans
c'est à dire que voiliers se revendique
de la laïcité tout en déconstruisant
complètement le le concept de laïcité
et ça c'est assez typique des frères
musulmans alors après est-ce que
islamistes c'est une insulte
bon c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
évident c'est tout simplement sans doute
un constat ensuite lorsqu'on intitule
un album djihad est con et compose avec
des tee-shirts ou ya écrit jihad
bon ben c'est qu'on ait djihadistes
d'ailleurs lui parle de djihadisme
intérieur etc
bon ok mais donc c 'est de l'islamisme
c'est à dire c'est un militantisme
politique autour de la religion
musulmane
bon voilà après aurore bergé je sais
qu'elle elle elle se fait une image de
combattante laïque
il se peut très bien que ça soit sincère
et dans ses très bien enfin bon mais je
pense que là elle a été exercée quand
même une histoire un petit peu l'ancien
je pense était pas forcément nécessaire
de remettre en selle mais voilà qu'on
constate aux insultes pour reprendre les
propos de renée fregosi concours lépine
parce que actuellement on a un concours
lépine de deux des personnalités
politiques de en marche qui chaque jour
essaye de trouver un nouveau truc pour
faire le buzz médiatique autour du thème
récurrent identitaire en marche a décidé
que la campagne présidentielle dans un
an devait se faire sur l'identitaire que
pour vous c'est une stratégie oui
complètement ben oui il n'ya pas de
hasard frédéric vidal qui commence par
penser que ce qui est aujourd'hui le
plus grand danger qui nous menace c'est
l'islamo gauchisme ensuite des ministres
des ministres qui réagissent au fait que
le maire de lyon vous rendez compte
quelle affaire le maire de lyon a fait
retirer de la viande des menus des
cantines scolaires quelle affaire waouh
c'est un truc hyper stratégique des
ministres qui réagissent à ça et
aujourd'hui hors berger qui est une
député de droite qui a été qui a adhéré
à l'ump à 16 ans qui a soutenu nicolas
sarkozy qui a fait toutes ses classes à
droite
aujourd'hui évidemment berger qui est
élu dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines quand même c'est à dire celle
qui était détenu par madame boutin alors
oui laure et d'eric moi c'est plus par
monsieur poisson alors aux bergers à ce
type dans 1 ans et les législatives il
faut que je il faut que j'y aille
et donc mais l'édile est sincère quand
même oui mais sauf que sauf que ça tient
pas la route une seconde pourquoi parce
que ce c'est bon moi je n'aime pas mais
tin
je n'aime pas de point de vue artistique
j'aime bien le rap
j'aime beaucoup soprano j'aime beaucoup
big flo et oli j'aime beaucoup black m
je n'aime pas je ne peux même pas ce qui
est écrit mais dit je n'aime pas sa
façon bête je n'aime pas son lourd que
j'aime pas que j'aime pas parce que je
pense qu'il ya aussi là dedans il ya
beaucoup de d'une volonté d'occuper des
créneaux il ya du business il vous savez
il ya voilà et ensuite sur là où aurore
bergé fait un contresens total c'est que
surtout ne jamais prendre au pied de la
lettre les paroles les textes qui sont
qui sont les étaient les textes de rap
pourquoi parce que le rap c'est
justement une forme d'écriture de
chansons qui consiste souvent à aligner
des choses que l'on veut absolument
dénoncé avec lesquels on n'est
absolument pas d'accord et donc on va
enfiler des phrases comme ça qu'ils
misent bout d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
dit mais d'une part pour se défendre il
dit mais elle a rien compris
justement je pense exactement inverse et
lui lorsqu'il faisait cette fameuse
conférence à l'école normale supérieure
il se revendique il dit moi la laïcité
ce n'est pas quelque chose dont j'ai
hérité par le drapeau ou par la patrie
c'est quelque chose dont j'ai hérité par
brassens brel ferré par le victor hugo
paris il sentait pas les trucs comme ça
non bien sûr oui à ferrer ferrer il n'a
pas chanté et si et si vraiment dieu
existe et comme le disait bakounine ce
camarade vitamines il faudrait s'en
débarrasser c'est une volonté ccc ferrer
qui a chanté ça ça s'appelle le chien
est bien mais aurore bergé le
déchaussement dehors si elle avait si
elle avait été député oran berges et à
ce moment là mais ferrer il n'aurait
jamais plus il n'aurait jamais pu
chanter nulle part il aurait été
interdit il aurait été interdit de
concert interdit d'antenne voyez c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné je pense que
franchement vouloir absolument chercher
de la polémique à travers des textes de
deux rappeurs qui sont qui sont des gens
qui essayent de dans un univers hyper
concurrentiel où on veut absolument
faire parler de soi moi je trouve c'est
pas sérieux et je crois qu'il ya aussi
autre chose qu'il faut voir c'est que au
sein de en marche
il ya un débat politique aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir sur quoi on doit être
sûr le pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle
et de toute évidence
la partie la droite dans marche et qui
est aujourd'hui la plus présente la plus
la plus visible et qui occupent les
postes clés avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et beaucoup d'autres cette
partie là elle veut que ce soit elle
veut surtout éviter que ce soit par
exemple sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire sur le social sur la réduction
des inégalités non il faut que ça porte
exclusivement sur l'identitaire et
aurore bergé
eh bien il faut lui reconnaître une
certaine un certain talent pour pour
accomplir cette mission je vous livre
les copains de feu aux internautes qui
sont assez inspiré nicole 0 su ce qu'il
nous dit pour une fois je soutiens
laurent berger alex sur youtube qui
s'interroge la question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'un islamistes
et puis
kriss kross kidioui veulent juste faire
le buzz je ne sais pas quoi en penser
baba sur youtube et quid de la liberté
d'expression myskina sur youtube un
rapport islamistes ça n'existe pas c'est
comme parler d'un vegan carnivores
peut-être que les islamistes font pas de
musique je voulais je suis pas
suffisamment faible pour le savoir à des
pans de sa dépend lesquels le rap c'est
du coran alternatifs comme aurait pu
dire la vie coluche bravo bobo 12 c'est
très drôle
et puis notre petit sondage express
comme on le fait toujours bien que ce
soit par un sondage mais surtout coup de
sonde sur twitter la député robert j at
elle raison de qualifier le rappeur
médine d'islamistes c'est oui à 70%
j'entends votre votre défense de médine
j smadja mais est ce que vous serez
d'accord pour être inquiet devant les
réactions qu'a provoquée la la la
position de robert j'ai regardé est là
elle a posté un tweet dans laquelle elle
explique que depuis 72 heures elle fait
l'objet d'un flot ininterrompu de
centaines d' insulte d'intimidation de
menaces on va te retrouvée égorgée toute
la famille devant tes yeux d'accord que
là il ya quand même un problème c'est
intolérable c'est intolérable
le problème c'est qu'il faut enfin je
veux dire le moi je défends pas du tout
médine je jeu j'essaie de faire
comprendre que aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas en permanence en permanence
alimenter le débat politique sur les
questions humanitaires de jeu pense que
vous avez tort de minimiser quand même
parce que dans les milieux que touchent
les rappeurs et dont médine ça banalise
quand même un discours et une violence à
l'égard des laïcs des chrétiens des
athées des juifs
évidemment parce que bon de
l'antisémitisme il entraîne aussi pas
mal dans ces milieux là donc je crois
que il faut pas minimiser moi ce qui me
choque aussi c'est quand même mais je
vous dis c'est une vieille histoire donc
je comprends pas pourquoi ça ressort
maintenant
mais bon les raisons que vous
et l'incident beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'exemples hélas mais mais moi quand
même ce qui me choque peut être encore
plus c'est que ça soit normale sup qui
invite le rappeur pour venir faire une
conférence alors que les amants
gauchisme et bien près voilà à s'effacer
lexus et de plus voilà donc ça ça me ça
me sam alerterait encore davantage mais
c'est une histoire un peu ancien veulent
donc le rap est une forme littéraire
extrêmement intéressante
ah oui ça m'intéresse moi je trouve ça
d'une grande qualité
je trouve ça assez pauvre et ce qui
m'étonne aussi c'est que d'après ce que
vous me dites pas ce que je suis prêt
non pas spécialiste d'europe met donc
beaucoup pas celui parle beaucoup et dit
oui c'est un oxymore match et c'est
comme si il jonglait avec le second
degré si le jeune anglais si facilement
avec le second degré on nous ferait pas
tant de procès dès qu'on fait une petite
blague ou une allusion un peu
aujourd'hui déplacée par rapport au
politiquement correct
donc je crois pas hélas que le second
degré soit si répandue que ça
aujourd'hui dans notre société
merci beaucoup je crois que ce sera le
mot de la fin merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi ce sera un
plaisir pour moi de vous retrouver lundi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro de
points de vue très bon week end
[Musique]